arizona keeps everybody up late into the
night despite fox news's very early call
trump supporters worry about voter
irregularities and the media continue to
agonize over those
terrible terrible white republican
voters i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com
we're going to get to all of the news in
just one second because believe it or
not
it is now thursday and the presidential
race is still not over there's still
ballots to be counted in arizona there
are still ballots to be counted in
pennsylvania
some of the networks have called
wisconsin and michigan in favor of joe
biden which means that the entire
election really does come down to these
those two states although we are still
waiting on
nevada as well we'll get to all of that
in just one second first
this holiday season more people are
going to be mailing stuff than ever
before i mean first of all it may be
difficult to get together with loved
ones you need to send stuff in the mail
or your business and you're selling
stuff via the mail well why would you
head on over to the post office when you
could do it all easily and safely and
securely from home
why not just use all the services of the
postal service but not have to go to the
post office this is what stamps.com is
for here at daily wire
we've been using stamps.com since 2017
we do not waste our time stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups directly to your
computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices or an online seller
fulfilling orders during this
record-setting holiday season or even a
giant warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it once
your mail is ready just schedule a pick
up or a drop off
it's that simple with stamps.com you get
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates it's a no-brainer it
takes you time and money
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts that is a fantastic deal
just head on over to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter shapiro again stamps.com enter
shapiro stamps.com never go
to the post office again okay so joe
biden is
basically preemptively declaring victory
he's not saying that he definitely won't
be saying yeah we're going to win
so here was joe biden yesterday walking
out to the cheers presumably of the
members of the media
declaring that they were on track to win
the presidential
election now
after a long night of counting it's
clear
that we're winning enough states to
reach 270 electoral votes needed to win
the presidency
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners okay
so um
that is not helpful in any way shape or
form it's also not helpful because the
fact of the matter
is there are still votes to be counted
in arizona so this morning
the arizona republic reported that
trump is actually getting the share of
votes you would need to reclaim arizona
according to the arizona republic dot
com
as maricopa county released the results
from 140 000 more ballots on wednesday
night and thursday morning
president donald trump received almost
the exact share he would need to charge
back to win
arizona's 11 electoral votes and
potentially re-election trump won the
batches of ballots from maricopa county
counted wednesday and early thursday by
roughly 57 to 40 margin over former vice
president joe biden
those votes likely early ballots sent to
the county on monday and tuesday
narrowed biden's lead over trump in
arizona to 68 000 votes his lead had
been
more than 90 000 votes earlier on
wednesday paul benson republican
pollster with the consulting firm
highground said trump needs to win 56.
57.6 percent
of the 470 thousand votes the arizona
republic estimates remain
to be counted he said that's almost
exactly what he got in the first patch
he could do it the problem for trump is
he needs to replicate that performance
across
all of the remaining 470 000 votes left
to count in the state he needs to do it
across all of arizona's 15 diverse
counties
that includes pima coconino coconino and
santa cruz counties
trump needs to repeat that performance
with every single batch every single
ballot every single day said bent
the first step in the long journey was a
successful rum intro
a successful one in trump's tightrope
walk
president trump also needs to maintain
that vote margin through different
batches of ballots that include those
that arrived in the mail before election
day early ballots dropped off at the
bulls on election day and provisional
ballots voters cast because they didn't
have the right form of identification
or they went to the wrong polling place
but this means that there is a pathway
that is still open in arizona and this
is giving everybody over at fox news
heartburn and it should give everybody
over at fox news harper because you'll
recall
that very very early on tuesday night
fox news called arizona in favor of joe
biden
and it really shifted the momentum of
what everybody was feeling because it
came
shortly after florida had been called
for trump it looked like trump was
running away
with florida now does that impact the
vote not really
okay there's some speculation that
perhaps the call in arizona came so
early that there were a few people
who are left in line that theoretically
could be a problem
but i believe the call didn't come like
five minutes in it came probably an hour
and a half
after arizona actually closed the polls
an hour after arizona closed the polls
so my guess is you're not talking about
thousands and thousands of people who
are left in line just to be perfectly
accurate about all of this
with that said fox news calling it early
was seen by a lot of people including a
lot of conservatives as a sign that fox
news wants to get away from trump just
generally
and it caused an awful lot of
consternation on fox news a trump
campaign official yesterday
reamed fox news for the early arizona
call
as this narrows there is going to be
great pressure on
you guys to be honest with you fox news
to rescind
your call it was it was a premature call
you know we were
livid about the fact that you and then
the ap made that call
there are seven organizations that call
states on election night from time to
time
seven five of those seven did not make
that call
okay guys we got it i agree we don't
want to be in a position
this is going to lead john biden to
falsely declare himself the
president-elect at some point understood
okay so this one there's a lot of
pressure on fox news
and uh you can see it actually on the
ground msnbc was reporting on a crowd
yesterday
outside some of the maricopa county
offices where the votes were being
counted
shouting fox news sucks right which is
not something that you normally hear
from crowds
of republican voters here's a little bit
of that footage
a loud and very boisterous crowd you'll
start here and then
start up here
they're actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because
fox news called arizona for
biden yesterday and a lot of people
are angry about that msnbc guys like
this is amazing
they're not shouting at me that's
amazing
probably the best clip from last night
was actually rachel maddow
when it finally dawned on her that trump
could actually win arizona because
remember the map is such
that if trump wins arizona and he wins
pennsylvania remember the votes are
still being counted in pennsylvania
guess who wins the election and so this
dawns on rachel maddow in real time and
steve kornacki who actually is quite
good at his job
is going through the stats and you can
see rachel maddow
almost begin to collapse in on herself
if things go this
this way we are looking at something
that looks very close to a tie
yeah and i i would just i'd say it at
this point because it's 75 000 out of
400 000 and change that are going to
come in so
we're not sure it's exactly going to be
59 when all is said and done if it ends
up at 55 i think he'll be short
if it ends up at 65 i think there's a
chance he would overtake biden there
so we haven't really established the
rate what we've established right now is
the possibility
okay and rachel maddow then starts to
almost fall apart
and it's it's pretty fantastic okay
meanwhile ron desantis the governor of
florida he rhema fox news as well he
said they should
you guys need to retract the call i mean
fox news was under heavy pressure for
the last 48 hours to retract a call that
obviously was premature
so here's ron desantis going after fox
news
trump is gaining in arizona there's
probably 500 000
so here's my thing sean if you're going
to be quick on the trigger
then be quick on the trigger for both
sides and stand by it but it seems like
with trump
they never want to call the state and
then biden man they'll do it right away
it's inconsistent it's unacceptable and
look north carolina should be called for
the president
uh for sure arizona that fox should
rescind that call
well meanwhile nate silver is saying the
same thing so this is not just
republican partisans like members of the
trump campaign
or ron desantis the governor of florida
and he's making a good point there too
which is it took them four
damned ever to call florida on election
night i mean it took like four hours for
them to call florida even though we all
knew within the first
hour because all of the ballots were
already in and were counted very very
quickly
florida has a very smooth because of
2000 tabulation
system they really come out with
excellent voter data very quickly
it took them forever to call that state
but arizona they were really quick on
the trigger and he's right about that
nate silver said
i don't know i guess i'd say that biden
will win arizona if he forced me to pick
but i sure as heck don't think the state
should have been called by anyone i
think the calls that were previously
made should be retracted now
that's nate silver so there's a lot of
heartburn out there
for people who think that this election
is already over it is worth noting here
by the way that georgia may end up in
the democratic lane that's how close all
of these states are so there's still
votes coming in in fulton county which
includes atlanta
it is quite possible that those votes
split in favor of joe biden
which means that joe biden would end up
winning georgia so you could see a
situation in which
trump loses the election because he
loses george georgia buddy wins arizona
and pennsylvania so
there's still a lot of outstanding
questions as to where this race is right
now plus
there are now lawsuits that are on the
books so anybody who's declaring that
the race is over
anybody who's declaring that this this
election is done not yet it ain't
not yet it ain't we'll get to more of
this in just one second first
we all hear the stories in the news a
good guy has to use a gun to protect his
family from criminals and then he gets
arrested after having to do so the legal
system may not be fair in some of these
situations responsibly armed americans
often become
political targets it's just not right
for good responsible americans to wind
up in jail or embroiled in a lawsuit for
defending themselves or their family but
in this day and age you need a gun to
protect your family and yourself
so here's how you can take a simple
powerful journey to firearms and
self-defense confidence it's called the
complete concealed carry
and family defense guide from the united
states concealed carry association the
uscca it is 100
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun even if you have small
children
and a whole lot more it's 164 pages it
comes with a bonus audio version
so you can listen whenever you want
right now there's a lot out there it's
unpredictable we see high
crime in various major cities you need
to protect yourself i mean you do but
you need to do it responsibly you need
to know how to do it and you need the
legal resources available in case god
forbid you have to fire your gun
in self-defense text ben to 87 222 to
hook up with my friends over at uscca
you'll get instant access and a chance
to win a thousand bucks so you can buy a
gun to protect your family text ben to
222 right now again text my name ben to
87 222 to get started with my friends
over
at the uscca okay meanwhile president
trump has now filed lawsuits in three
separate states according to the
associated press
president trump's campaign filed
lawsuits wednesday in pennsylvania
michigan and georgia
laying the groundwork for contesting
battleground states as he slipped behind
democrat joe biden in the hunt
for 270 electoral college votes needed
to win the white house
the new filings joining existing
republican legal challenges in
pennsylvania and nevada demand better
access for campaign observers to
locations where ballots are being
processed and counted and raised
absentee ballot concerns the campaign
said
however at one michigan location in
question the ap observed poll watchers
from both sides
monitoring on wednesday i am enjoying
the ap using
one example of bad things not happening
to now suggest that the
lawsuit is baseless we'll find out
whether the lawsuits are baseless
the trump campaign availing itself of
the courts in order to ensure that there
are
enough poll watchers at particular
polling stations that is perfectly
within the balance of legal and
perfectly within the bounds of the
predictable and you would assume that
all of this is going to hash out in the
courts and in the end
the ap has already called michigan for
joe biden on wednesday nevada
pennsylvania georgia arizona these are
all undecided
the trump campaign is also seeking to
intervene in a pennsylvania case at the
supreme court that deals with whether
ballots received up to three days after
the election can be counted according to
deputy campaign manager justin clark and
that is because
in the lower court order there was a
suggestion that ballots received after
election day that were not postmarked
before elections they could still be
counted which is totally crazy
and that could mean that your ballot
packing after the election is already
over
now you start to see the ballots come in
you start to see that the race is too
close to call and you say to yourself
okay well i didn't vote i'm gonna go and
i'm gonna vote now
okay you can't do that that is that is
election fraud right if you actually
vote after election day election day is
called election day for a reason there
is no such thing as election day part
two
the trump campaign also announced he
would ask for a recount in the state of
wisconsin
a state that ap called for biden on
wednesday afternoon campaign manager
bill stephen cited irregularities in
several wisconsin counties
without providing specifics it is
unlikely that a recount in wisconsin
will result in a
trump victory in wisconsin scott walker
former governor of wisconsin now the
head of young america's foundation which
is an excellent organization
he says that we've had recounts in the
state before tends to move a couple
hundred votes
doesn't move 20 000 votes
biden's campaign spokesman andrew bates
said legal challenges were not the
behavior of a winning campaign
this is what makes these charades
especially pathetic is that while trump
is demanding recounts in places he has
already lost
he simultaneously engaged in fruitless
attempts to halt the counting of votes
in other states in which he's on the
road to defeat okay and this has become
the talking point for democrats
because in some states you're hearing
republican voters chance
chance count the votes like in arizona
right and meanwhile
over in michigan they're literally
shouting stop the count
right because they are worried about the
possibility of voter irregularities so
here is some footage
from protesters in michigan shouting to
stop the count
okay so this has been used by democrats
as an excuse to
proclaim that republicans are attempting
to engage in voter suppression because
you have some people chanting stop the
count in michigan
and other people in arizona chanting
count the votes
first of all stop the count also happens
to be this is the best tweet of
yesterday that i saw
that also happens to be a chance that
was very popular
around transylvanian castles back in
about 1870.
right stop the count but in any case the
uh in any case
it that is that is intellectually
dishonest to suggest that because people
want
some vote count stopped in michigan and
other people in arizona want the
votes to be counted that that is an
inconsistency as kimberly strassel of
the wall street journal points out
she says lots of folks saying
incorrectly gop wants to both count and
stop ballots at the same time
let's be more precise there are three
categories republicans calling to count
votes that came in by election day or
before per state law
that is obvious right that'd be arizona
two republicans calling to halt votes
until gop observers given access
to vote counting known as suggesting the
votes not be counted only that
republicans be allowed to witness the
counting why not transparency is good or
is confidence in outcome
that would be michigan three republicans
questioning states that want to count
votes that contravene state law on
deadlines
left is claiming this is
disenfranchisement but why laws are laws
we're all expected to follow them and
why should some states get extra
judicially granted privileges
not others and that would be
pennsylvania right so you can't treat
every state as though it is the same in
arizona there's not a lot of
accusations of voter irregularities
we'll get to a couple of accusations
that turned out not to be true yesterday
in michigan there are accusations that
poll watchers who are republicans have
been thrown out of the
polling places and so are not able to
monitor properly
we'll see whether there's evidence of
that and then in pennsylvania there are
serious questions about
how exactly the votes are being counted
right are you actually tabulating
ballots that are coming in
after the election day and doing so even
if they were not postmarked before
election day right that's an open
question
so to pretend that there is uh that
there is some sort of
inconsistency there for republicans is
to be intellectually dishonest it's not
intellectually honest
to suggest that all situations no matter
how different ought to be treated
exactly the same
that's the point that kimberly stressful
is making okay so with that said
republicans
are focused very heavily on the
possibility of voter irregularities
deciding the election now i i don't
think that that is the case i do not
think that voter irregularities are
going to decide the election i think
that we have a bevy of systems across
the country
that's actually a fairly good protection
against widespread
nationalized voter fraud if you had a
centralized system in washington dc
that was actually handled by a federal
bureaucrat that would be a lot more
troublesome
than having this bevy of systems all
over the country with that said
when the sausage gets made it can be
very ugly
right and people don't pay a lot of
attention to how the sausage is made
until
voting day and then it's like oh my gosh
look at that there are batches of
mail-in ballots that are being brought
in well yeah i mean how did you think
they got counted somebody had to drive
them over in a car and then they got
counted
does that open the possibility for voter
fraud sure why not it could
but you actually have to evidence voter
fraud if you're going to suggest that
voter fraud is the rationale
for a particular loss i don't like when
democrats do this democrats have done
this for years
stacey abrams is still walking around
out there in the wilderness claiming
that she is the governor of georgia
because of voter suppression without any
evidence
so i want the lawsuits to go forward i
think it is good for transparency i
think it is good for the american people
to feel safe and secure in their
elections
i think all proof should be brought and
i think it's good that people are
eagle-eyed i mean getting all sorts of
emails from people asking about voter
irregularities it's good to be
eagle-eyed
about voter irregularities but then we
have to investigate it's not just enough
to put the accusation out there you
actually have to show
that there is in fact a real problem
we'll get to this in just one second
because we should be as accurate about
all of this
i think as possible in the interest of
the country in the interest of holding
clean and fair elections
the election may not be fair for other
reasons we'll get to the media's
intervention in this election because
frankly to me if you're going to talk
about impacts on elections
that seem unfair just in a generalized
sense
the media's intervention in this
election was obviously unfair corporate
intervention in the election is unfair
social media intervention in the
election is unfair but the voting system
itself calling that into question
has some pretty powerless consequences
so we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that the second amendment
is pretty damned important
in fact it's so important that i'm quite
relieved that it looks like republicans
are going to hold the senate
because if joe biden had his way he
would be looking to confiscate your guns
right now and who knows he may try to do
it from the executive office
if he ends up as president god forbid
anyway well this is why you need to
protect your second amendment rights you
know who agrees
the folks over bravo company
manufacturing bravo company started in
the garage with a veteran of the us
marine corps in heartland wisconsin
the people at bravo company mfg support
the right of responsible private
individuals to have the access and
ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement as a means of
defending ourselves
our loved ones our communities and our
freedoms should a threatening situation
ever rise
bravo company manufacturing is not a
sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas
so quality is of utmost value to them
every component of a bcm rifle is
hand-assembled and tested by americans
in heartland wisconsin
to a life-saving standard as an american
you have the luxury of living in a free
society where you can improve
your life through education religious
exploration the open exchange of ideas
all of those rights are protected by the
second amendment the folks at bravo
company manufacturing know that they
know the responsibility of making
excellent firearms head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com you can discover
more about their products special offers
upcoming news that's bravo company
mfg.com
find out even more about bcm and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa okay so
as i say a lot of accusations of voter
fraud andy mccarthy
who writes about this sort of stuff for
national review obviously
a an excellent lawyer and a trump voter
as well andy mccarthy has a piece today
about
voter fraud and i think it is worthwhile
going through the piece because i think
this is this is relevant
he says on the matter of vote fraud
there is law and there are facts we'll
hear plenty about fraud but we'll have
to remind ourselves to ask did it make a
difference
even if the trump campaign has potential
claims in law they would collapse if
as a matter of fact they would not
affect the outcome of race pennsylvania
which i've discussed extensively over
the last three weeks is a good example
as repeatedly recounted the state
supreme court by fiat ordered a
three-day extension of the november
third election day deadline for the
state's receipt of mail-in votes
i.e until close of business november 6th
i believe this was an unconstitutional
usurpation
of the state the state legislature's
power to set the rules for elections
if so that would give the trump campaign
a basis to seek the supreme court's
intervention
indeed four justices on the high court
were poised to stay at grant
are poised to grant a stay against the
state court's order
in mid-october just last week three of
those justices induced
pennsylvania to agree to segregate the
ballots received during the three-day
extension
anticipating the court might review the
matter on an expedited basis after
election day
in addition the trump campaign could
also argue there was a significant
potential for vote fraud because of the
presumption the pennsylvania court
imposed on its extension order
ballots are to be deemed that timely
submitted even if they lack a legible
postmark or any post mark at all
proving they were mailed on or before
november 3rd obviously this creates the
possibility ballots could be harvested
and submitted post-election without
postmarks right this is what i'm talking
about pennsylvania that lawsuit is
well-founded
so says andy mccarthy we have a viable
legal claim and a potential for fraud in
the battleground state
it was reasonably anticipated could
decide the election clearly that was why
a number of supreme court justices were
inclined to intervene
and yet all of this only matters if
there are enough late arriving ballots
to change the result
right before i appeared on fox news on
wednesday afternoon to talk about this
legal terrain bill hemmer interviewed an
election official from lucerne county
northeastern pennsylvania's most
populous county with over 320 000 people
he explained that for all the legal
huffing and puffing over illegality and
fraud
only about 200 ballots arrived by mail
then on wednesday obviously each day we
get further from november 3rd we should
expect fewer ballots to the point where
it's down to a trickle on friday
now there are 67 counties in
pennsylvania but if that is a late
if that is the late arrival rate in
lucerne most counties are going to have
fewer many will have significantly fewer
as i write this post at 6 pm wednesday
evening pennsylvania is reporting 87
percent of the statewide vote is in
president trump leads by 4.8 that
translates to almost 300 000 votes
now says andy mccarthy it is certainly
possible the remaining 13
of the vote could break heavily for
former vp biden and he could eke out a
razor thin win in which case every vote
might count
and then there would be a convincing
legal claim it is also equally likely
that either trump holds on and wins the
state or
the vote breaks so sharply for biden
that biden wins by one or two points
in the first of those latter two
scenarios the likely illegality and
potential fraud would be irrelevant you
wouldn't have standing
and even if biden wins it only matters
if so many biden ballots arrived between
november 4th and 6th
that they could have been the difference
maker shifting the contest from trump to
biden
right and this is something to keep in
mind as we move forward
spotting an instance of voter
irregularity is not evidence that the
voter irregularity is so significant
statistically that it would actually
shift the nature of the election itself
in order for example for wisconsin to
have to have been decided by voter
irregularity
you would have to assume that the 20 000
vote margin
would be swamped by voter fraud we've
not seen evidence of that sort of
widespread voter fraud the same thing in
pennsylvania we'll have to see how the
pennsylvania account
comes out that's the point that mccarthy
is making nonetheless yesterday the
trump
campaign held a press conference eric
trump appeared there rudy giuliani
appeared there here was eric trump
yesterday suggesting that voter fraud is
rife
in pennsylvania and philadelphia in
particular they're trying to cheat they
have
three by five printed big posters
in polling locations all over the city
saying to vote for
biden harris which is totally illegal
they're passing out flyers
and now they won't let and we brought
one great gentleman here with us today
jeremy
who's a poll watcher down to the
convention center they won't even let
him watch
as they count the ballots they put them
behind the fence 40
50 yards away where they actually can't
see the counting happening
guys this is fraud this is absolute
fraud
okay so to clarify on that particular
allegation
i think it's important that we actually
go through the allegations that we're as
factual as possible
about this election i think that the
system breeds distrust
i think that all of the systems should
run like florida does i think the sort
of haphazard way that all these systems
are run is really not particularly good
but
as far as that first allegation that for
example people
are uh posting signs in polling places
telling people to vote for biden
in violation of the law the philadelphia
district attorney's office
did investigate the allegation they
tweeted out the polling places located
in an interior room the signing question
is further than 10 feet from that the
tweet is deliberately deceptive
so not a ton of evidence that that
amounts to voter fraud as far as people
not being able to watch because they're
placed
too far away again lawsuits are being
filed on this basis a similar lawsuit
is being filed in michigan on that basis
so if you are staking the results of the
election
on lawsuits alleging voter fraud you
have to imagine that those are
probably not going to be the the
deciding factor in the election either
trump wins arizona and philadelphia and
pennsylvania
outright i don't think the lawsuits are
going to shift around the nature of the
election
i just i i don't think they will just to
be perfectly blunt about it
we'll get to more of the allegations
over over voter irregularity and voter
fraud
in just one second first let us talk
about something
amazing that you can do for yourself for
your family okay so on your phone you
have tons of photos right
what are you actually done with those
photos just sit there on your phone
because
who has the time to go and make like a
little book and like that takes
hours you're not gonna do that what if
you could just take that that photo
and you could email it with like one
quick and easy email and now you would
get back
all of the possible ways that you could
frame that thing print that thing out
put it on a beautiful piece of material
that's what my photo is for my photo is
a game changer
it is crazy easy and crazy fast to take
any photo and make it into a metal
piece a glass piece wood or more it
literally takes two minutes to do it i
get it in five days it comes in a
stunning gift box this makes a fabulous
holiday gift
with the holidays coming up i barely
need to do anything to make something so
personal
and special i sent us a picture of my
family from a recent wedding
and uh it came back in this beautiful
glass frame it is just
it's amazing i mean it's colorful and
gorgeous these guys have literally made
millions of customers memories come to
life you got to try it right now and
it's very
easy just head on over to myphoto.com
you can easily see your photo on all
their products and then simply purchase
you can use the promo code ben25 today
for 25 percent off i have several
of their pieces in my house again it's
quick and it's easy it doesn't take time
and it's fantastic i mean just makes
your house look beautiful go to
myphoto.com
right now use the code bend25 get 25
off you'll see how easy and fun it is it
is fantastic easy
fast anyone can do it don't just let
those photos sit down your phone doing
nothing instead go to myphoto.com right
now
use the code bend25 get 25 off i know
the founders of the company
really fantastic trustworthy people go
check out myphoto.com
right now and use my code ben25 to get
to 25
off your purchase okay so again lots of
allegations
from team trump that there is uh voter
fraud this is all going to get litigated
it's all going to get litigated so just
i'm telling everybody not to call the
election because there's still
outstanding votes because there's still
outstanding litigation and i'm saying
the same thing to republicans before
republicans declare that the election
has been quote unquote stolen
before they declare that it's a foregone
conclusion that the election has been
stolen
this is all going to get litigated there
is a process for this stuff and i think
it's important to remember that that
this process is going to move forward
so kelly mcinerney suggested that
philadelphia has a history of peculiar
results she's not wrong about this again
i'm not saying the suspicions are wrong
i'm just saying
let's wait let's wait is less weight a
bad thing i don't think lots weight is a
bad thing here's kaylee mcinning
philadelphia in particular has a history
a very peculiar results you had um in
the case 59 different precincts where
mitt romney
got precisely zero votes which is very
unlikely and curious indeed just six
months ago you had a philadelphia judge
who was convicted in a scheme to accept
bribes as he cast
fraudulent ballots four months ago you
had a democrat individual who was
charged for in 2014 2015 and in 2016
stuffing the ballot box with fraudulent
ballots so we want to be on alert
okay and that is perfectly acceptable it
is is perfect anybody who's saying that
they shouldn't be on alert
why not this is an extraordinarily close
election it's gonna be decided by
thousands
not hundreds of thousands of votes in
places ranging from arizona and georgia
and pennsylvania to wisconsin and
michigan this is an extraordinarily
extraordinarily close election like a
very very close election
okay so with that said that means that
we should actually
you know take a solid look at the
allegations that are are being put out
there
so right now there was an allegation
that was put out there
that people were covering up windows in
michigan and on the face of this this
does look really suspicious right
they're a bunch of people outside who
are attempting to see what's going on
inside a place where the votes are being
counted and suddenly see workers
bringing over poster board to cover up
the windows
nothing quite says transparency and
openness like covering up actual windows
here's some footage of that
okay so that obviously is not exactly a
great look
so what exactly happened in michigan so
according to the detroit free press they
say the issue was sparked when some poll
challengers were not allowed into the
counting area
as limits had already been reached
republicans and democrats are each
legally allowed to have 134 challengers
observe at the counting process
according to the detroit news
issues flared when both parties had more
than 200 challengers in the room
exceeding the limit
republicans complained that the block on
challengers entering the hall had
allowed more democrats to be president
to observe the count so they were saying
yeah we have 134 but they've got 175
challengers who are being allowed
into the room police stood outside the
entrance of the center to prevent
further challengers from entering the
building
to observe the tallying of results in
the key swing state
footage posted on twitter by a
washington post photojournalist solomon
georges
showed a few dozen people gathered
outside the hall a smaller portion
raising their fist and chanting
stop the count newsweek contacted the
michigan department of state for further
details and comment
while the situation unfolded in detroit
president trump's reelection campaign
filed a lawsuit at the michigan court of
claims arguing they had not been
provided with meaningful access to
counting locations so they could observe
the counting
of the ballots michigan secretary of
state jocelyn benson who is a trump
opponent it is worth leaving note
later dubbed the lawsuit frivolous and
claimed its complaints did not have
merit
but we will see whether that is true
because again all of this is going to
end up
in litigation the apparent michigan
secretary of state suggests that uh the
covering up of the windows
uh is is was about people looking in
and uh and not being allowed legally in
and then trying to
gather information based on that
uh about voters like looking at ballots
they weren't supposed to be looking at
in any case that'll be investigated it
should be investigated because why the
hell not everything should be
investigated okay another story that
came out yesterday that people were
suggesting was indicative
of voter fraud it is called the sharpie
story so you're hearing a lot of rumors
yesterday in arizona
that people had been told that they
could fill in their ballots with sharpie
and then those ballots
filled in and sharpie were not actually
processable by the machines
well that turns out not to be true
here's the arizona secretary of state
katie hobbs
pointing out that all of those ballots
have in fact been processed and will be
processed
there is no concern about ballots being
counted
because of the the pen that was used to
mark the ballots
all of those ballots are being counted
um and even if the machines can't read
them for some reason
a marker led through to the other side
we have ways to count them they're going
to be counted
there is absolutely no merit
to saying that this was some conspiracy
to invalidate republican ballots it just
there is no there there at all okay it
is worthy of note also that this was
being live streamed so you could
actually tune in in real time
and watch the ballots being counted so
there are recount provisions of arizona
law
um and uh she says that she says that
there
the provisions of of recounting in
arizona law it has to be within a
particular kind of margin of error we'll
see whether it is inside that margin
of error so wolf blitzer did ask about
the the sharpie situation
he said have you heard of that is there
any truth to that claim she said i've
been talking about markers all day today
certainly i want to validate voters who
have concerns about their ballots being
counted
there's no concern about ballots being
counted because of the pen that was used
to mark the ballots all of the ballots
are going to be counted
all of them okay so that is where things
stand
there was also some rumors yesterday
people saying things like well look at
that there are more
votes in wisconsin than registered
voters in wisconsin wisconsin has same
day voter registration
so that that is why you're seeing those
stats again worthy of myth busting this
sort of stuff simply so that we know
exactly what the scope of voter fraud is
and the scope of potential voter fraud
and the scope of potential voter
irregularity now the truth is that this
has been
a pretty calm process i mean for a
country that was sort of on the edge of
a cataclysm
it seems like the process has been
pretty calm many of the people who are
showing up and protesting
are protesting peacefully like i haven't
seen any violence breaking out at the
polling places i haven't seen
republicans punching people because
they're so angry about what's going on
or anything like that
didn't stop end msnbc from freaking out
so there's a crowd maricopa county
literally just standing around
and there's an msnbc reporter who's
freaking out as though the like these
people are kneeling and praying
and the msnbc reporter is like we're all
gonna die
what do we do here is msnbc
covering you know people peacefully
protesting by claiming that they're
they're on the verge of breaking into
rioting and looting
this is the same network that actually
covered rioting and looting as though
they were on the verge of breaking into
prayer here was msnbc covering a
peaceful protest
right now they're they're kneeling in
prayer but one of the things that we've
seen
is them chanting very loudly
count that vote count that vote and then
we've got poll workers that are coming
off of shift
and the poll workers have to be escorted
out by
armed sheriff's deputies down those
stairs and into vans and taken
away from here so this is a type uh the
type of scene that we're seeing we're
gonna get
a little bit closer here we don't want
to get too close a lot of people
in the crowd are are not wearing masks
okay so um you know obviously this is
scary scary stuff over at msnbc they
were also freaking out in detroit where
there were republicans showing up at the
polling places to make sure the votes
were counted
and msc for msnbc freaked out about that
as well
what we see here is essentially
an increasing mob like scene of
self-proclaimed
poll watchers who say that they want to
get access to the building so many of
them
have rushed into the building here that
i'm actually talking to
official democratic poll watchers from
the democratic party
who've been shot outside of the
balloting room
which they're supposed to have access to
eamon it's gotten to the point where we
do have a police presence here that is
blocking access to the building
because not only have they swarmed the
room but they are now over
in terms of covered restrictions wow i
mean
i mean they're look at these people look
how dangerous they look right behind her
i mean doesn't that look like just a
terrifying scene
it was mostly peaceful though they
should just claim that they were
protesting black lives matter and then
everything would be totally fine by the
way there were protesters out there
in in some of the major cities yesterday
uh there was a protester spitting on an
officer in the west village i didn't see
msnbc
covering it quite the same way we'll get
to that in just one second first
you've heard me talk about my helix
sleep mattress right you've heard me
talk about how important it is to me
because i need to have
my sleep it needs to be good because i
don't have that many hours available to
do it
well helix sleep those people who make
excellent mattresses well now they've
launched a new company it's called all
form they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door what makes
an offer sofa really cool well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores
you can pick your fabric it's spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs sofa size and
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everybody and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you want
your all-form sofa to grow and change
with you when you move
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your door in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa you would need to
hire somebody to come and assemble it in
your home or break your back trying to
put it together yourself
not so with all forms they have a simple
quick assembly no tools needed i've got
in all forms so if i've got that
three-seat sofa
with chase and the sand color with
espresso legs it's fantastic my kids
love it
it's so comfortable then when we have
guests come over very often they
actually shun the bed and they're like
i'm sleeping on this hall form sofa it's
that comfortable
if getting a self without trying it in
the store sounds risky don't worry get
100 days to decide if you want to keep
it that is more than three months
if you don't love it they will pick it
up for free and give you a full refund
they also have a forever warranty
literally forever to find that perfect
sofa
check out allforum.com all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allform.com check them out
right now okay so while msnbc was
freaking out over people who are
literally standing outside polling
prices and
pulling places and praying there are
actual crazy people who continue to do
crazy things all over the country
over in the west village a protester
spit on an officer didn't go well for
her it turns out this is a bad strategy
when you actually assault an officer
there's a good shot that you're going to
be arrested
um but don't worry it was mostly
peaceful mostly peaceful spitting on
officers
uh g good times all the way around oh i
i will say that this has not been
without its amusements this entire
process
probably the most viral moment of
yesterday happened when um there was a
presser in nevada and a man
with a shirt reading barbecue bureau and
freedom invaded to shut down
an announcement that votes were not
going to be released yesterday
the media is covering up the fighting
crime family stealing this election
the media is covering it up the mighty
deputy is covered up we want our freedom
for the world
give us our freedom to abide in your
mind is covering up this election
he's stealing that um
okay so yeah things things are still
going great but here's the truth
this election for all the talk leading
up to about how this is gonna be chaotic
and horrific
it has not been and in fact it turns out
this has been an excellent
excellent election for republicans okay
excellent election for republicans
broadly speaking
there are a bunch of new indicators
about how well republicans did
across the united states republicans are
likely to pick up anywhere from seven to
13 seats in the house
which nobody saw coming republicans are
likely to hold the senate at this point
in time there may be two runoffs in
georgia it is highly likely that
republicans win both runoffs in georgia
republicans are going to hold the seat
in montana they're going to hold the
seat in maine and they're going to hold
the seat
in north carolina and and so even if joe
biden is god forbid elected president
when all of this is said and done
he's going to be facing down a
republican majority in the senate which
is a very different presidency than joe
biden thought he was going to be facing
in fact
joe biden is the first democratic
president elected
since 1884 not to enter office with a
democratic majority in both the house
and the senate
in that incredible stat he's the first
elected demo if he wins
he will be the first elected democratic
president who does not enter office
with his party in control of both the
house and the senate and that's gonna
make an awful lot of difference because
and you can see in the markets by the
way the markets are are really
looking good this morning the reason
they're looking good is not because
they're excited about joe biden
it's because they're excited the
democrats didn't take over all the
facets of government
the the markets were afraid elizabeth
warren was going to be secretary of the
treasury that ain't happening
the markets were afraid bernie sanders
was going to run policy mitch mcconnell
is the head of the senate so like that
is very very good news for the country
that gridlock is going to be good for
the country and by the way it sets up
republicans really well for 2022.
if god forbid biden is the president and
mitch mcconnell is the head
of the the senate he's the senate
majority leader and it's not kamala
harris who's breaking ties or something
well what that means is that republicans
are now set up probably to win the house
in 2022 and probably to extend their
senate lead in 2022 and everybody knows
it including the democrats which is why
you're seeing so much depression on
their side of the aisle
i was reliably informed that all they
cared about to restore the soul of the
country was getting rid of donald trump
then why are they so disappointed when
it looks like they're on the verge of
doing that
the answer is because it wasn't about
that it's about how much they dislike
republicans how much they dislike
conservatives it wasn't sufficient
for them to defeat trump it was never
about trump it was about you
and that's why they're so all fired
upset they're upset that donald trump
won that many votes they are upset that
mitch mcconnell is still the senate
majority leader they're upset that
republicans gained seats by the way not
noticing a lot of articles about the
historic number of republican women who
were elected
it's only like 13 republican women are
now were elected in this election cycle
in the house
haven't seen any stories about the the
new feminist breakthrough
have you oh yeah that only works when
talking about democrats of course
we'll get some more of this in just a
second because honestly these are major
victories for conservatism these are
major victories for republicans
and they shouldn't be they should not be
ignored just because we're all still
focused on what could happen in the
presidential race which remains
very fraught we'll get some more of that
in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that i've
been talking to you about sleep quality
how important sleep equality is
well i'll tell you one thing that helps
your sleep quality immensely your pillow
your sheet right you got a great pillow
and great sheets it makes a world of
difference a world of difference
i've improved my sleep quality
dramatically because i am now lying upon
my pillow pillows and my pillow sheets
and they're fantastic
mike lintel is the inventor of my pillow
mike's latest deal is on his giza dreams
sheets they're made from the world's
best cotton
is a cotton they are ultra soft and
breathable and breathable extremely
durable
right now those giza dream sheets are at
a two for one low price plus free
shipping with promo code daily wire
all of the my pillow products come with
a 60 day money money-back guarantee just
head on over to mypillow.com click
on the radio listener square to check
out the two-for-one low price on the
giza dream sheets plus free shipping
there are also deep discounts on all
other mypillow products as well enter
promo code dailywire or call
800-651-1114
for these fantastic radio specials go
check out mypillow.com
honestly quality pillows quality shoes
that ain't going to get better than this
go check them out right now enter promo
code dailywire or call 800-651-1148 for
that
fantastic offer okay we're gonna get to
much much more because
i'm gonna bring you a lot of good news
like all the way around the country good
news for conservatives
and the and the continued reliance on a
racial narrative
by the democrats that spells frankly
future wins for republicans coming up
we'll get to that in one second first
you may have noticed that this year has
been just a complete bleep show it feels
like america is coming apart and it
feels like the democratic party is out
to undermine fundamental american values
that was what was at stake in the
election i think the american public
more than anything else
reproached the 1619 project and the
wokeness of the left
and i i hope that we contributed to that
with my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps
now as we move forward in this country
it's gonna be very important that
particularly young people
who voted in outsized numbers for
democrats understand
exactly what is going on when people rip
into the history of the united states
and the philosophy of the united states
i get questions all the time what's a
good book i can recommend to a college
student a high school student
to a friend to educate them about why
america is fantastic
about why the declaration the
constitution are important and why
people are attacking them my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps is
that book i think it is the single best
primer
available on the history philosophy and
culture of the united states and why
there are people who want to tear those
down go check out the book how to
destroy america in three easy steps more
relevant today as we move forward with
our educational mission
than ever so make sure that you go check
that out right now
also make sure you head on over to
dailywire and subscribe we have so much
good stuff coming for your candice owens
joining the team moving with us to
nashville
we have all sorts of excellent new
programming coming for you go subscribe
right now be part of the team
help us replace the corrupt media that's
what we are out there to do
go check us out right now daily wire and
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so the excellent news for republicans
really was coast to coast
over the course of the evening and the
presidential race is still
up in the air again we don't know the
outcome of the presidential race
yet trump has some steep hills to climb
still in arizona he's got some hills to
climb
in nevada he's got some hills to climb
in pennsylvania but we don't know the
outcome yet but one thing is for certain
and you can see it you can sense it
democrats are deeply unhappy with the
result they are really unhappy with the
result even if joe biden ekes out a very
narrow victory
they're very unhappy with the result and
the reason they're unhappy with the
result is again
it was never about getting rid of trump
this was the lie of the campaign the lie
of the campaign is that democrats were
deeply concerned about trump's character
that was the only thing they were
worried about
no no they were using that as a front
for the usual leftist claptrap the usual
leftist agenda they were hoping
to ride dislike of trump into the white
house with a
big majority in the senate and they were
hoping they would then be able to cram
down their unpopular agenda on the
american people it's why joe biden
refused to talk about his policies the
entire campaign
because it was all lie it was never
about trump's character it's about you
they think that you
if you're a trump supporter or you if
you don't vote for them you're a bad
person you're a lesser person and voters
rejected that
not only did they reject that they
rejected that in extraordinary ways
republicans are set up for the next four
to eight years
in a pretty solid way going forward hey
the new york times reporting
some suburban strongholds swing back to
gop in new york and across the united
states
heading into election day democrats in
new york had high hopes across the
ballot with three house rates as
targeted in a national red to blue
campaign
but by wednesday morning these hopes
were greatly dimmed you can hear the
despair
reeking from the new york times the
three democratic candidates all women
were far behind after the initial
machine count ballot
elsewhere in the state two first term
democratic congressman max rose and
anthony brandisi were in danger of
losing their seats
just two years earlier they'd been
hailed by their party as trailblazers
who prevailed in districts traditionally
held by republicans
in the state capitol where democrats
harbored visions of a super majority in
the state senate the party seemed far
from that goal and may even cede ground
the republican hold on the suburbs
seemed to wane in 2018 with democrats
taking seats in new york and similar
suburban districts in other states
on tuesday the tide seemed to turn back
again reflecting the republican success
at ousting house incumbents in swing
districts across the country
that trend was mirrored nationally in
results from state houses with the
lowest number of chambers slated to
change hands in more than half a century
while democrats won both legislative
houses in arizona they lost both the
house and the senate in new hampshire
while some republican candidates sought
to distance themselves from president
trump
whose popularity was thought to be
waiting they still clung to a trump-like
law and order message and it turns out
by the way as we'll talk about in just a
second that law and order message is
durable with minority
minority audiences it turns out you know
who doesn't like rioting and looting a
lot of black folks who live next to
people who are riding and looting a lot
of hispanic folks
don't like illegal immigration it turns
out that you don't have to pander
and pretend to pander to a racial group
in order to win their votes
it turns out that people act as
individuals and in their own best
interest
and they can assess their own best
interest as individuals
hey that is what republicans found out
last in the last couple nights
according to the new york times they
tied democratic candidates to defunding
the police and progressive radicalism in
the party a strategy that seemed to work
in many parts of the nation as
republicans sought to maintain control
of the senate and claw back
some house seats definitely worked in
south florida where
cuban population the venezuelan
population they voted in outsized
numbers for president trump
because they don't like socialism and
they don't like what the democratic
party is preaching
max max rose was targeted in a series of
attack ads from the congressional
leadership fund that featured a group of
men in police union shirts criticizing
him for marching with demonstrators
calling to defund police departments
similar strategies were employed by the
trump campaign and republicans across
the country
democrats were initially slow to push
back a reluctance that some democratic
lawmakers and strategists warned
would backfire so republicans are
starting to win back
those suburban districts that the
democrats thought were permanently lost
to them
meanwhile according to politico a decade
of power
state house wins position gop to
dominate redistricting
here's something else republicans can be
happy about tuesday okay this is
actually huge news because i was deeply
worried about this a bad election cycle
to uh to have a bad election cycle is
anyone ending in zero because every
ten years that is a a census year
okay in the census is when redistricting
is done and when redistricting is done
that is a real problem if you have the
opposite party doing those district
drawings
an abysmal showing by democrats in state
legislative races on tuesday
not only denied them victories in sun
belt and rust belt states that would
have positioned them to advance their
policy agenda it also put the party at a
disadvantage
ahead of the redistricting that will
determine the balance of power for the
next decade
the results could domino through
politics in america helping the gop draw
favorable congressional and state
legislative maps by ensuring
democrats remain the minority party in
key state legislatures
ultimately it could mean more
republicans in washington and in state
capitals
by wednesday night democrats had not
flipped a single state house chamber in
its favor
it remained completely blocked from the
map making progress making
process in several key states including
texas north carolina and florida
which could have combined 82
congressional seats by 2022 where the
gop retained control
of the state legislatures after months
of record-breaking fundraising by their
candidates and a constellation of
outside groups
democrats fell far short of their goals
and failed to build on their 2018
success
and they may have president donald trump
to blame it's clear that trump isn't an
anchor for the republican legislative
candidates he's a buoy
said christina palisa a spokesperson for
the democratic legislative campaign
committee
he outperformed media expectations
democratic and republican expectations
and lifted legislative candidates
with him okay that may or may not be
true because
he performed basically in line with most
of the candidates around the various
states for example
in georgia the senate candidates seem to
have won more votes than trump did but
he certainly was not an anchor that part
is certainly true
right trump drove enthusiasm voters came
to the polls to defend trump and they
voted for republicans in the process
and a lot of people split the ballot a
lot of people came and they voted for
joe biden at the top of the ballot and
then they said you know what i don't
want that guy
actually generating policy i just don't
like trump very much personally and then
they voted down ballot for republicans
there was some ticket splitting here
democrats had a disappointing night in
congressional and state legislative
races across the country
as they realized the suburban revolt
against trump did not extend in 2020.
that is one of the theories that was out
there is that in 2018 the only way
that you could provide a referendum on
trump was to vote against republicans
who sided with him
but trump himself was on the ballot so
there are a lot of people who are like
okay i can vote against trump and also
for my favorite republican congress
person
or at least against the democrats
republicans appear poised to hold on to
the senate gain seats in the house pick
up a governorship in montana defying
expectations
but it is the victories they won in
state legislatures that could be the
most consequential of all
giving the gop outside influence over
the congressional and legislative
redistricting process that begins early
next year this is why the democrats are
freaking the hell out they are freaking
out
and democrats are deeply afraid of all
of this they are not happy
this morning they're not happy on
thursday
it doesn't matter that they think they
now have the upper hand in the
presidential race
it's really honestly it's really funny
to watch some of the lincoln project
members today because like look we're
getting rid of trump aren't you guys so
happy
aren't you guys so happy and meanwhile
the democrats are like i can't believe
this went this badly
because it turns out it was never about
trump for the democrats never
it was always about the pursuit of power
i mean there's an article in the
washington post today called democrats
ambitious agenda for 2021 runs into an
unexpected obstacle
mcconnell's resilience yes yes
feel your anger
this is good this is very good news okay
so republicans have a lot to be positive
about even as we out
even as we wait out the final results of
the election
and so that is a all of that is very
very good news and that should be
celebrated
by republicans coast to coast and
conservative frankly americans coast to
coast because you don't want
the radicals in charge of the government
you don't no matter what you think of
trump it is very obvious americans do
not want the radicals in charge of the
government with unchecked power
that is not a thing that's why am i kind
of sanguine about the georgia senate
races that are going to
probably have runoffs in january i'm
kind of sanguine about it i don't think
the georgians
are going to show up on mass to give joe
biden a majority in the senate i just
don't think that's going to happen i
think mitch mcconnell is very likely to
be the senate majority leader
when the next president is inaugurated
or even if trump is
re-inaugurated uh in in january okay
meanwhile
you can sense the despair in liberal
circles they're desperately attempting
to cling to a narrative
that they've been pushing for quite a
while okay that narrative is that
racial racial polarization needs to
happen in order to better the country
there's only one problem with that in
this election cycle the republicans did
better with black voters and they did
better with hispanic voters
now doing better with black voters did
not mean that black voters did not put
biden over the top
by pulling data black voters did put
biden over the top the difference
between biden
and trump if biden ends up winning which
again is still pending
if that happened the reason would be
because of heavy black turnout so you
can win a heavier share of the black
turnout but if the black turnout overall
is larger that means more absolute votes
in the black community
went for joe biden so for example in
michigan
there are 94 000 black voters in in
there are 308 this is uh this is
according to andre banks
of we win black and color of change he
said
there were 94 000 black voters in
michigan in 2016 there were 389 thousand
voters
in michigan in 2020 and that makes the
difference
in the presidential battlegrounds in
2016 black voters cast 2.7
these are early votes actually black
voters cast 2.7 million ballots early in
the presidential battlegrounds in 2016.
in 2020 they cast six million votes
early
nationally black voters in 2016 cast 4.4
million votes early
in 2020 it was 9.7 million votes early
right so heavy black turnout did spur
biden to an advantage if he ends up
winning this election with that said one
thing that was completely repudiated
here
was the idea that you can absolutely
tell the future of the country
simply by looking at the racial
polarization in the country it is just
not true
trump won a historic number of minority
voters trump won more
minority voters just on on a percentage
basis than any republican candidate
since 1960.
what that means is that we are actually
watching maybe i we can all pray and
hope
the end of intersectionality rather than
the beginning democrats had basically
banked on
the idea that some woke white ladies
along with
typical liberal millennials and youngers
together with a minority coalition a
heavily minority coalition polarized
into obedience to the democratic party
line by accusations of racism against
republicans
that would be the new coalition the new
governing coalition for democrats
and it turns out that that is falling
apart on them and they are
just they're not going to let it go
they're angry about it and they are not
going to let it go
it doesn't matter that the data do not
support this contention that they are
going to be able to use the demographics
his destiny argument
and build their coalition on the back of
an intersectional racial coalition
i mean this is this is what's amazing
i mean if you actually look at the
polling stats in minority communities i
know that we're not supposed to actually
look at what
people who are black or hispanic think
about the world we're just supposed to
treat them as a monolith according to
democrats
but it turns out they have some ideas
that don't exactly drive with the
democratic party line
according to a piece at nbc news from
musa al garby
he says it may be the minority viewer
viewers
sorry it may be that many minority
voters simply do not view some of
trump's controversial comments and
policies is racist
too often scholars try to test whether
something is racist by looking
exclusively at whether the rhetoric or
proposals they disagree with
resonate with whites they frequently
don't even bother to test whether they
might appeal to minorities as well
the article is saying is that basically
pollsters and
media members will find if a policy is
popular with white people and then
they'll say ah if it's popular with
white people it must be
racial animus but what if some of those
policies are also popular with black
people so for example school choice
when they do look at the opinions of
black and hispanic americans the results
tend to be surprising says this
columnist for nbc news
for instance one recent study presented
white black and hispanic voters with
messages
the researchers considered to be racial
dog whistles or coded language that
signals a commitment to white supremacy
it turned out the messages resonated
just as strongly with blacks as they did
with whites
hispanics responded even more warmly to
the rhetoric about crime and immigration
than other racial groups
that is on balance these quote-unquote
racist messages
seem to resonate more strongly with
minorities than whites across racial
groups most did not find the messages to
be racist or offensive
despite the researchers viewing these
examples as clear-cut cases of racial
dog whistles
right so in other words when donald
trump said i don't think america's
systemically racist or when donald trump
says i don't like illegal immigration
when donald trump says we need law and
order in our cities
all of the pollsters all the media
members like ah that's racism we all
know it's not racism and you know who
else knows it's not racism
many blacks and hispanics but democrats
are never gonna let go of this they're
never gonna let go of it because
they think they discovered that they
they had they had performed alchemy
right they transformed they had
transformed rust into gold
this is what they thought they thought
that they had taken the the
marxist the marxist brew and poured it
into a racial vessel
and the racial vessel would be capable
of carrying the marxist brew that's what
they thought
they thought that they could just pour a
bunch of socialistic big government
nonsense
into a vessel that was all about
rage against quote-unquote white
supremacy and that would hold it it
turns out that vessel doesn't exist it
turns out that people are still
individuals but the media aren't going
to let go of it so the worst column of
the day comes
from the aptly named charles m blow at
the new york times
his column is called exit polls point to
the power of white patriarchy
really do they do they point to the
power of white patriarchy because it
turns out that trump won an elevated
share of the black vote in an elevated
chair of the hispanic vote
and in fact he wanted to press share of
the white boat particularly
but charles blow has a theory and he's
never gonna let those facts get in the
way of the theory we can never let the
facts get in the way of the theory he
says
it is obscene that the presidential race
is too close to call at the time this
column is published
wednesday 6 30 pm eastern standard time
after all that donald trump has done
all the misery he has caused all the
racism he has aroused
so roughly half the country voted to
extend this horror show
let me be specific and explicit here
white people both men and women were the
only group
in which a majority voted for trump
according to exit polls to be exact
nearly three out of every five white
voters in america
are trump voters it is so unsettling to
consider that many of our fellow country
men and women are either racist or
accommodate racist or acquiesce to
racists right so
i love this you're just gonna keep
calling everybody a racist just keep
doing it man just keep doing it until
you are in the permanent political
minority please we're enjoying i mean
let's be real about this it is that
sentiment that has caused the upsearch
for trump it is that sentiment that
caused a rejection of woke-ism all
across the country keep doubling down
keep saying everybody you disagree with
is a racist see what it brings you see
how much people appreciate it
it turns out people think you're a
jackass it turns out that when you call
person people racist without evidence
and your only evidence is you disagree
with them that makes you a jerk it makes
you a bigot
okay in charleston blows a bigot hey
here's what charles blow says
this is my favorite part he says not
just white people who are the problem
it's all the people who want to be white
people
see now white has become a synonym in
woke land for evil
so if you're white you're evil right and
also if you are
black and you voted like the white
people
then you are also evil because now
you're white on the inside right this is
just
it's gross disgusting stuff that's been
pushed by the racial left for quite a
while here
he says that's only part of what was
shocking to me about the exit polls
first the stipulations
as the new york times makes clear these
data are preliminary estimates second
some people
wondered whether the exit polls would
include voters who voted early or by
mail
finally exit polls are just exit polls
but i am still stunned
yeah i'm sure you are a larger
percentage of every racial minority
voted for trump this year than in 2016.
among blacks and hispanics this
percentage grew among both men and women
although men were more likely to vote
for trump than women
among hispanics the movement by sex were
marginal and held remarkably steady over
the last four presidential elections
the fascinating story and movement are
in the black vote black people vote
overwhelmingly for democratic candidates
black women vote more reliably
democratic than black men
only three or four percent of black
women voted for the republican candidate
in 08 12 and 16.
however trump doubled that number this
year winning eight percent of black
women's votes
black men have been inching away from
the democrats in recent elections
five percent of black men voted for
mccain in 2012 11 for romney
13 for trump this year 18 voted for
trump
these men were specifically targeted by
the trump campaign that targeting it may
well have worked
democrats are going to have to pour some
energy into specifics listening to and
understanding these black men they are
still the least likely group of men to
vote republican but this trend away from
democrats is undeniable
at this point also as it turns out 28
of lgbt people voted for donald trump
so what is his conclusion here's his
conclusion
right not that maybe people vote as
individuals and that you can approach
them as individuals and that they can
have disagreements on a variety of
issues and still vote for a candidate
no charles blows his con his his
conclusion is all these people have been
taken over
by the by the parasitical white
patriarchy
all of this says charles blow points me
to the power of white patriarchy and the
hotel it has of those who depend on it
or aspire to it
it reaches across gender and sexual
orientation and even race
trump's brash privileged chest trumping
and alpha male dismissiveness and
interface rudeness are aspirational to
some men and appealing to some women
some people who have historically been
oppressed will stand with the oppressors
and will aspire to power by proximity uh
there it is so
you are now white black men if you voted
for donald trump congratulations
you have been conferred with evil
whiteness by charles blow
gay people you are now straight by
virtue of the fact that you voted for
donald trump
women you're now men by virtue of the
fact that you voted for donald trump
according to charles blow but don't
worry
you're the bigot you're the bigot it's
absolutely unbelievable keep doubling
down on this crap please do it
do it do it
okay and it's not just charles blow who
again is terrible it is the washington
post political reporter for the fix
eugene scott
quote these days i am reminded quite
often that you do not have to be white
to support white supremacy uh you're not
white anymore you see
you support white supremacy that's
that's it all those black men
who voted those 18 of black men who
voted for trump they're all big fans of
white supremacy as it turns out weird
we're all a bit weird but i mean if
eugene's got and that is some heavy
journalism right there that is some hot
sticky heavy journalism right there from
eugene scott
he's just tubing his journalism all over
the place right there he's a political
reporter
for the by the way i love his profile
this shows you the nature of our crap
media and why we need a replacement
media right now go subscribe to daily
wire this is it right here in a nutshell
here is his profile eugene scott
washington post political reporter for
the fix
all politics is identity politics all
politics
is identity politics unbelievable
unbelievable so you're overtly stating
your religious worldview and this is
considered good journalism
solid solid stuff really really good
meanwhile nicole hannah jones the
defacto editor of the new york times
another one of these papers of record
again replace the media they're garbage
nicole hannah jones the author of the
1619 project which is a
pseudo-historical piece of dreck
award with the pulitzer prize because
the people who award those sorts of
prizes
don't like america very much she tweeted
out also whiteness is not static it is
expandable when necessary
a lot of folks we don't think of as
white think of themselves as white
because the lines have never been
entirely clear that's the beauty of
white supremacy it is extremely
adaptable
well no that's the beauty of white
supremacy to you because you get to use
the term white supremacy to slather on
anything you don't like
white supremacy is actually not an
adaptable term it means something quite
specific
historically speaking it means people
who believe that white people are
supreme
white supremacy right that's what it
means but according to members of our
steamed media establishment
white supremacy it's it's a beautiful
excuse for everything
it's a plastic you can you can it's like
peanut butter you put it over anything
and it makes it taste better
or in this case tastes worse or in in
this case excuse any sort of behavior
karen atia who of course is one of our
esteemed journalistic bettors
she runs global opinions at the
washington post who's journalist of the
year
and she wrote white women again because
white women
are ee though white women
oh white women okay so i have to say one
of my favorite exchanges yesterday there
was an exchange
on on twitter and i i gotta find it for
you because
it it's just it's so good okay so here
is the exchange
it is between a woman whose name i'm
going to mispronounce
not on purpose but just because i i
literally don't know how to pronounce
this name
i'm gonna i'll try okay i believe that
it is kelly bogil
zvogo so forgive me if i mispronounce it
she tweeted out a graphic showing the
voting breakdown in the
in the exit polls white people we will
not forget this is how y'all roll
election after election okay anne-marie
slaughter
who is a former harvard law professor
and princeton dean uh she worked at the
state department under barack obama
she'll probably be in the biden
administration
if biden ends up being president she
tweeted whoa
what about those white people in the
blue column those of us who believe that
a plurality america will be a better
america than a white majority
america okay so first of all that is in
and of itself racist is it not
because the reverse is also racist if
you say a white america will indubitably
under all circumstances be better than a
plurality america
that's kind of racist because now you're
assuming that whiteness is the is the
deciding factor in whether the country
is good or not so now she's saying
that non-whiteness is the deciding
factor but that's not the part that's
funny okay so she says
what about the white people who are
voting along with you why are you
cutting a cell why are you being so mean
and kelli bogle zvogo writes back i have
tremendous respect for you but i cannot
accept this response
overwhelming majorities of people of
color notably black women consistently
vote to elect leaders who will be humane
and we keep getting left in the lurch
okay so
black women are the heroes white women
are are bad and even amory slaughter who
votes the way you want her to
she's part of the white female problem
so what does anne marie slaughter do
this is my this is the best part
this is the best part she apologizes
she apologizes for saying that many
white women did not support donald trump
quote to all the people on this thread
including new america folks i hear you
and apologize
i do not mean to deflect attention from
the realities of racism and the deep
racial divide between voters on the
right and the left
i see how hashtag not all white people
does that just like hashtag not all men
ah so the wokeness will never stop
it will never stop okay there will be no
coming together as long as the woke
rule the roost and they're gonna rule
the roof so long as the democrats
believe that the future of their party
lies
in the intersectional coalition building
started by barack obama
particularly in the 2012 election until
they get over that
it's going to get worse and let's just
be frank about this the more democrats
decide to go down this path the more
republicans are going to win
so by all means continue like i think
for the good of the country should
abandon it
i would prefer that we have two parties
that stand for individual identity
rather than group identity i think that
would be better for a for a country
that is dependent on the idea of having
discussions and having free speech
but if you're not going to do it if
you're going to go for it then fine go
for it and we'll see how it works out
for you
it's a bold move cotton we'll see how it
plays alrighty we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haase executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci event
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
[Music]